well the mystery continues as to what
will happen to the dozens of veteran
residents at share village after their
landlord was forced to abandon the
complex christian casadas joining us now
live in studio with a better look at
what's happening inside that complex
christian well denise several sheriff
village residents tell me they noticed
changes around the complex months ago
many taken back when they were notified
that the person that spearheaded the
property was stepping down and crucial
services began to fade away
the biggest thing everyone feels is
let down
kick to the curb it's been an emotional
and difficult time for virginia fosso as
her veteran complex on las vegas
boulevard she says is slowly fading away
services were taken away
donations were taken away we used to
have a community room where we had
clothing
maybe small appliance donations reading
materials books and it was our our
cooking center we have the full kitchen
there well
that was taken away and now it's a room
for rent people who live here tell eight
news now notices were recently issued
stating the property manager arnold
stock had covered and was stepping down
in august
but that move was quickly halted on
tuesday by property owner ysbm
investments llc after clark county
district court denied the company to
seek a replacement nobody knows what's
going on with the leases or the rent or
any of the arrangements there i don't
know either a grim future for dozens of
residents who fought for our country and
now they say are left in the dark why
did you just leave us dump us like an
abandoned dog about in the desert with
nothing
these people don't deserve it
these veterans don't need it
the biggest question is why did you do
this arnie
lots of questions all right so in court
documents ysbm stated they didn't know
how to run a non-profit court documents
also showed a number of utilities are
unpaid some in excess of 50 thousand
dollars so the future of those living at
share village remains uncertain denise